first talk to me a little bit about
jumping into the horror thriller uh
genre again kind of for the first time
since jennifer's body and this film
is like man it's like a wild game of saw
and some toxic relationship what
intrigued you about this role
i think that like i it's not really a
comedy the same way jennifer's body was
but it did strike me
as situationally very funny maybe no one
else would find that
funny but the idea of like being chained
to
your dad has been to killed himself as a
punishment for your bad behavior
it it's hilarious it's crazy i know i'm
with you
we're not leaving until we open that
safe 200 grand
in rocks we split the diamonds let's go
two people knew the combination to that
safety the guy who hired us
and the girl but it was just different
than anything else i had read
or seen there are some like gerald's
game elements or
even like ready or not i guess with some
of the visuals you could draw on that
but
it just i haven't done anything like
that i haven't done like a marriage
drama before i haven't done like a
grown-up movie i haven't done
a traditional thriller or horror movie
before because jennifer's body was not
that it was very much
like a teen angsty dark
comedy and this is not it's nothing like
that it's a thriller
a psychological thriller a marriage
drama
um it is supposed to have some comedic
elements as well but definitely don't
use this as your instruction manual on
how you should or should not proceed
this thing was supposed to be shot let's
see uh the pandemic pushed it from
shooting march 2020 to the summer in
bulgaria and then you were inside a
studio which
watching as a spectator you're like oh
my goodness art design and this thing is
remarkable tell me about
creating that winter wonderland inside
and what that was like for you
they did create and one of the studios
this the millennium studios in bulgaria
is insane that's one of the nicest
studios i've been in
but they created an entire property that
looked like something out of upstate new
york that was completely snow covered
um a cabin a half full house um
because we had to be able to actually
like drag him down and upstairs and out
of bedrooms and
so all of that was real um
and it was it was amazing no i mean it
looks great tell me more about your
co-star stuntman i mean
you're like what's it like being an
actress while you drag a
much glow off of this um he was amazing
uh he was heavy and i was
chained to him the whole time and
um you know his job was to play dead so
he was like actually dead
and i i was handcuffed to him and i had
to pull him around through all of the
scenes and
it wasn't easy i mean you know i'm
strong but not that strong after hour
13 it kind of gets a little trying
it's crazy because it's like the
ultimate definition of excess
x baggage as i'm watching this thing i'm
like it's like the
in my mind i'm dragging around my ex is
right
like a visual joke that is the joke yeah
it is it's good what let me ask you a
question
what is what is your advice on not being
in a toxic relationship what is your
advice on being in a non-relationship
that reflects
uh till death you know um i think you
just have to be aligned with
yourself and you have to remove your ego
as much as possible you have to be
selfless meaning
you have to always prioritize loving the
other person where they are
as they are who they are in this moment
talk to me a little bit about the
the underwater scene at the end i i i
was
like full of anxiety as i'm seeing this
guy hooked to you and he's hooked to him
everybody's going
down it's so scary what was it like
filming that that was kind of stressful
because
we did all of that for real i was still
chained to him while we were doing it
most of it
and um you know i'm good i'm good in the
water i'm a good swimmer i was a
competitive swimmer as a kid it's
different though and the cameras are
rolling
and you also have to fake drown then all
of a sudden you are losing your air and
you do kind of there were a couple of
times i did panic like am i gonna make
it up to the surface
time um it's all mental of course but
um that was a cool scene there were two
men in the scene
both huge like muscular dudes um
and i was fighting my way back up to the
service to break the ice
um it was intense it was it was i forgot
all about that
until you just mentioned it that was an
intense let me ask you you said you
um you swam before so did you hop back
in the pool at all to kind of like get
in get in shape or do a little
preparation
for water work in this no because i just
had to
fake drown so it didn't require
but that's also something like i did it
competitively for years so you don't
really forget how to do that i didn't
have to get back in the pool
i mean it plays intense and it plays
really well if you don't mind me asking
what's colson's take when he sees a
scene like that has he seen any of this
movie yet
he he's seen some of it he was at adr
with me at one point but he hasn't seen
the whole movie so he hasn't seen that
yet
does he like you in that world that kind
of you know edgy thriller world or does
he feel uncomfortable when he kind of
sees you do stuff like that
no i mean he's an actor as well and an
artist so he likes to see
the different facets of what what i can
do for work and like
how i can push myself or be someone that
i'm
actually not and how good i can
hopefully be be at accomplishing that
and selling that
i mean it's i always think like oh if
you're connected to that person that's
drowning
so well on screen it's got to be
unsettling
okay so we we we're saying listen don't
live your relationship by this movie but
if there was a lesson
you could gain from this movie what do
you hope the audience takes from it
i just don't know if it's very
philosophical this movie but
uh a lesson from this movie
break up or get divorced before you
cheat
doesn't ever work out well for anyone
could end up changed to a dead person
listen
that is a really good sell that should
have been the log line for this thing
so when you do a strenuous role like
this is it fun or is it like all
intensity i know you're doing like you
said you're dragging this dude around
it's a lot of physical stuff is it fun
for you is it really really working no
it's a lot of fun
there is like it is work of course but
it's a lot of fun i prefer movies that
are stunt heavy and like really physical
and um i have the best time making those
i i don't do well
sitting still talking all day every day
in a room
that's not as inspiring to me as
something like this so i had a great
time
and i'll always choose movies like this
over something that's more contained
you